[Musique]
même condition météo même température
demain matin sur l'ensemble du
territoire yvelinois avec quelques
éclaircies il fera 11 degrés dans le
Nord et le Sud du département dans
l'après-midi prévoyait un temps qui vire
à l'orage avec quelques averses côté
température il fera 13 degrés à
Rambouillet 14 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdan et ce vendredi 24
mars nous fêterons les quatre idées
alors Céline quels sont les prévisions
météo pour ce week-end
alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous c'est Thomas Fletcher je suis là
pour vous présenter la météo de vos
weekends beaucoup de motivation avant de
commencer si vous avez des réclamations
à faire sur mes prévisions
météorologiques n'hésitez pas à me
contacter sur l'adresse mail qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pendant
cette météo nous irons à votre rencontre
à la rencontre des yvelinois et donc
c'est parti alors quoi de beau ce
week-end samedi sachez qu'à titre
d'information c'est la journée de la
procrastination donc pour moi flemme
c'est ma première on prend notre temps
donc je vous laisse profiter de nos
Yvelines
voilà
voilà voilà dimanche il va pleuvoir
toute la journée dans les Yvelines dans
la matinée à Rambouillet il fera 8
degrés vers Houdan il fera plus 7 degrés
donc pas non plus des grosses
températures dans la matinée c'est pas
moi qui décide dans l'après-midi nous
atteindrons les 10 degrés sur Versailles
et Rambouillet toujours de la pluie ça
rime il nous faut de l'eau pour pour nos
petits pots et nous allons maintenant
aller voir vous je dis bien vous les
Yvelinois il y a un gros changement ce
week-end c'est le changement d'heure
nous allons voir ça avec vous ce que
vous en pensez et s'il y a des montres à
régler alors est-ce que vous savez que
du coup ce weekend c'est le changement
d'heure non jamais je savais pas et ben
ça fait plaisir de vous la prendre
plus tard
on avance on recule alors ah non là vous
me posez trop de questions
est-ce qu'on perd une heure on gagne une
heure vous savez c'est pas réfléchi
marron et ben on va dormir pareil
[Musique]
je sais plus on verra bien au moment où
je me couche à 7h25 exactement je me
réveille donc là ce sera 6h25 non ça
sera 7h25 8h25 non ça sera 7h25 juste
7h25
madame cette interview est fatiguante
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors quoi de beau